tonight is one of the most epic battles
the story that we tell in this
particular fight scene revolves around
devil and bullseye coroner's fake
daredevil when I was watching the fight
I really had trouble remembering who to
root for it's 3:40 in the morning we're
in church somewhere in Manhattan and I'm
exhausted but I'm also having a lot of
fun beating the [ __ ] out of Matt Murdock
what's interesting about our fight
sequences that Emma cannot let there be
any distance between them because
bullseye can use anything that he can
pick up
daredevil is trying to keep bullseye
close
but in an effort to also try and protect
Karen page at times yes they kind of
sacrificed the upper hand Dex is trying
to get a little bit of distance so you
can puncture you with something that he
throws of your face the stunt team gets
the scripts and we will design the
action is daredevil he's close quarters
combat fighter
whereas bullseye is more of a marksman
at this point in the game meet Chris
first of my stunt double know each other
very very well he's very aware of what I
am capable of and so once they've kind
of choreograph the fight and designed it
Chris will be able to identify which
pieces I'll be able to do one more time
that was great Charlie's amazing every
season Charlie does more and more of the
actual action he trains harder than any
actor and most on people that I know
that's it my brain and feels like
porridge my face feels like porridge and
I think we feel like this is pressure to
kind of pop off so I forgive
you